hello welcome back to GameSpot's
continuing coverage of Penny Arcade Expo
2014 my name is Donnie Anwar and I'm
glad to be joined by mr. Adam Urbano
pleasure NetherRealm Studios that's me
you guys are making a new walk on my
game that's what I hear yeah it's you
guys have had a sort of a renaissance an
MK of the past like five or six years
yeah and what's the new challenge where
Mortal Kombat X the goal is so with nine
we rebooted the franchise back to the
basics 2d functionality with really good
looking graphics and balance with X the
challenges how do we take that and
advance that storyline all those
features and make it something that is
the next true Mortal Kombat game after
the reboot you guys are leaning into
that storyline pretty hard getting back
in MK vs. DC obviously he's a big part
of MK 9 as well now we've got Johnny
Cage having babies what the goddamn hell
is happening
so X being sort of a metaphor for
obviously MKX the 10th version of the of
the franchise but also the next
generation of consoles ok and the next
generation of characters sure so you're
gonna see a lot of growth through story
takes place between 5 and 25 years after
the events of MK 9 so you get to see
things like Johnny cages daughter Cassie
yeah can you fight her as Johnny Cage
yeah you can great video games you know
we got some we got some b-roll of the
game here I played a bit of it at
Gamescom you guys unveiled a bunch of
new characters as well and talk a little
bit the the sort of the new characters
are common to the franchise because
obviously you know sub-zero scorpion
those staples we've already seen a lot
of yep so some of those from new
characters the franchise overall we have
Kotal Kahn sort of an Aztec based
fighter a lot of powers based upon light
and darkness and sort of traditional
values we have Farah and tour my sort of
favorite because you get this giant sort
of guy in tour and then the little
personal in the back yeah that's
terrifying yeah I said that fatalities
awful splitting down the middle
yeah very nicely yeah the next gen stuff
lets us do some pretty cool stuff with
hard fatalities and then you're looking
at we have Devorah
that we've
sort of this insect-based character a
lot of powers based upon those features
she uses and it's one of the cool things
is we designed them to kind of fit the
MK lore we wanted people to sort of
immediately recognize these as
characters that they feel yeah they've
known forever
I feel like a Mikael are pretty broad
though yeah well you got ninjas vice and
then the dude dudes would freaking spurt
this Baraka have a baby
we're looking at some footage here yeah
we got some well one very familiar
character and writing I might actually
know on Kano is what everybody to this
is one of our newer jungle levels and
we're seeing an example of Raiden sort
of various powers because one of the
things we've done with this game one of
the big gameplay features is variants
yeah so you've like split is that every
characters got three different sets of
moves that so they there move set like
at its core is still shared across
characters we don't want you have to
learn three different ranges but they
each have these fundamental powers that
are unique to each branch each variation
and it changed the way you play so
you're gonna have more defensive along
one particular variant versus something
more offensive your strategy is gonna
change or you have different unique
specials and abilities it's really cool
and really fun the balance was that ever
a worry considering while combat has
always been the sort of more accessible
of the fighting games that like you're
gonna over complicate things from people
yeah so we're very cognizant of that so
you wanted to make sure that this isn't
something you can change during gameplay
and then sort of the core mechanics that
you can still you know whatever variant
you choose is there so the variants are
sort of more something that affects
strategy and gives you additional moves
but if you just want to sort of button
match and just have a good time it's
gonna be the same across all the
variants yeah as well speaking about the
sort of differences between MK and a
bunch of other fighting games you guys
are kind of always sat on the periphery
of the fighting game community in terms
of that like any sports or in terms of
like competitive stuff is that always a
has not been a concern maybe this time
around that you guys want to get get in
on that is up maybe with the variants
are kind of well Luke 9 actually was our
first foray into sort of the technical
fighters and then Evo gives an Evo game
and it was something that we were really
focused on you know getting into that
sort of serious market and the
credibility
so the MKX we're taking everything we
learned and making sure that everything
available for sort of
tournament level player is there because
that's something we'd want you know it's
the easy to learn lifetime to master
concepts as well as just sick ass
oh god that's great yeah okay
so that obviously is a fatality next-gen
fatality where we can do all the things
we've always wanted letting the people
that come up with some still a little
crazy that ladies generation of consoles
has finally allowed ed boons nasty death
fantasies to become real all of the
team's fantasies to come risk not just
add in the room with a piece of paper
just right now okay no to burst through
ratings head I want that little girl to
slice straight down ladies box with her
what a nice he's certainly very much
kind of the visionary of each fatality
but yeah it's not him alone in a in a
room I think he appreciates the help now
this is a fighting game coming out and
if working in this side of the video
games industry is anything you guys are
gonna be trickling out details and
specifics over the next coming weeks and
months it's time for so many yeah so I'm
gonna guess if I well I have asked you
what characters are coming I'm probably
you you guys have a plan to like start
telling people real slow right yeah we
can sort of that's the kind of thing I
think about is how to keep people you
know excited and interested in some of
the crazy choices we made on roster
fatalities could be anything friendships
I could be anything all right that's
fair enough
another thing you get when I was playing
in games cameras are another thing you
guys and I have done as a kind of
leaning for that environmental and
killing or environmental interact
interactions yes yeah cuz there was a
there was a pin an island and 9dc there
was sort of the the transition stuff yep
there was a bit of nine and they seem to
be a lot more of them or maybe maybe
easier to trigger it yeah MKX so it's uh
it's something we explored with
injustice it was a chance to go a little
crazy with a new franchise try things
that you know wouldn't necessarily fit
in m'kay
and then we took the stuff that really
worked out well and we kind of adjusted
it to fit that Mk universe so you're
gonna see stuff all along the fight line
that you can just play with and it's
really easy to use
you know r1 and then you suddenly go and
throw a tree or jump off of an object
and there's traps there's offensive
there's defensive stuff and it's super
sort of casual accessible but you can do
things like combo into them and use them
as part of your attacks if you're more
of an advanced player yes I remember
seeing one in the jungle stage what it
was it was a vine hanging down and it
actually enables you to sort of leap
across which is kind of a new yeah yes
like almost like moving around the map
it changes yeah it is to give you sort
of it take away some of the advantages
that you would typically have like if
you're in a corner there's a lot of
interactable that let you escape that
yeah yeah yeah so you're not getting
pummeled all the time so we really
enjoyed that chance to kind of scatter
those objects like that tree stump which
just glowed all across the sort of fight
line yeah and here we are looking at to
found favorites scorpion sub-zero and
how do you take a guy like scorpion
specifically who I guess people are used
to an entire move set off and almost
like a mound nerf in but like split it
up like I know like Sub Zero Connect
throw his ice clone in one of the dip
modes
what's it yeah do you think that might
like fans leave it maybe arcs that I
can't you like teleportation moves as
well as flame moves or so we've been
really careful to make sure that the
court you know the core character even
before you picked your variant has all
the stuff that people sort of relate to
the character the core stuff you would
know from you know MK 1 in the arcade
and classic feel so you're still gonna
it's gonna have your traditional sort of
scorpion throw spears and his teleport
but it's the addition of new moves you
get in the variants that way we're not
sort of breaking that traditional
character because we're obviously very
sort of aware of what these characters
are and how important they are to keep
you know perfectly classic you guys had
this em playable for a price and stuff
at Gamescom is there is a playable on
the show for at all no sadly is it
holding the Bastille holding it back a
lot of the reason is there's stuff that
we're super excited about that we're
just not quite ready to show ok so once
we get that together we'll be ready to
go soon I'm very soon I like it yeah
what's that like I guess getting a game
like game chaos into people's hands like
you've been involved in the franchise
for a while now yep DC how important is
it like that sort of aspect of it of
like actually watching people play wow
it's almost painful until you get to
that point because we're so excited to
get people's hands on it and especially
as we sort of hit the balanced stage and
sort of
tune and learn about it we bring in
people so we have a group of you know
either
people we just invite or tournament
players that we get to have if that
early look and help us and then once we
hit the show floor that's when the fun
magic happens and you'll see us just
standing there watching for hours
because it's you know you learn a ton
and it's really cool to see how people
focus on stuff we didn't actually think
they would yeah so right in here
fighting a new character yeah so that's
that's total con
so that's the Aztec based character that
is Nihon in the surname does that mean
that he or she is some sort of I don't
know important top-tier character uh
they're all important in terms of the
the the the tower in terms of the is
there any Shao Kahn no there's a geez
it's just Kotal Kahn sort of more is
that South American Aztec reference more
than okay he's gotta take character I
thought it was like a son or a cousin or
a nephew yeah most people do so now he's
all new and again he's designed so that
he feels like somebody would have been
around forever that was a brutal look
there you're seeing there's some of what
brutal means particularly for this guy
either just throw a friggin barrel full
of lemons um yep so that's some of the
interactions and then here you're seeing
the variations on the characters just
gonna guess this was a crazy one this is
like you can almost make sort of like
barriers yeah of multiple like lightning
bolts I love that one so it's it's very
much focused around defense and traps
and hiding so you're seeing him like
bring up these ice ice are these
electric little balls that become
defensive units around you and where you
place them and how you use them become
sort of the core of the heck character
so yeah him using the power of the Sun
in that case oh yeah
kick to the jaw is that massive tiger in
the background interactive it is
actually you can jump off his head and
maybe at some point he gets angry okay
fair enough
so there's total cons x-ray oh god
that's the that's the worst that how is
he able to fight after that it's
ridiculous and largely because if I'm
not giving a damn all combats realism
yeah well it wouldn't be much fun first
hit they'd be dead so here we're gonna
see another one
oh gosh Oh dot it's just the worst yep
right
Yeah right wins so fatalities obviously
always being a big focus of m'kay a lot
of fun to make so a lot of new tech went
into making sure that you know and then
the team can do whatever they want axles
and when will players be able to do
whatever they want it's coming out of a
bunch of platforms whenever it's we're
gonna be able to play more complex sort
of the window of 2015 okay so we're
gonna be you're gonna be teasing at that
those details over the next couple of
weeks one of the fun things that people
get to learn very hopefully very soon
okay Papa Rock Hannon okay if you still
taking yep suggestions perfect Baraka
has a kid yet with reptile all right
okay done Dave out of these yep
friendly melodies no no no no there may
be friendships yep okay okay I will
email it right after this so I guess
that's in the game awesome I'm serious
thank very much come on over stage show
take me I enjoy the rest of packs